many of these girls started their sexual
life at nine ten eleven years old
these are children and and they never
ever been loved I'm in Romania a country
sadly synonymous with trafficking the
victims here are getting younger and
they rely on the kindness of a few if
they're lucky I'm on a journey to meet a
remarkable woman hello Jana we have just
arrived we're by the gate my name is
Jana Marte and I am working with victims
of trafficking since 1998 for 20 years
basically operating a safe place for
them Jana is a psychologist by training
and she runs this Center in rural
Romania at the moment there are 12 girls
here young women she's rescued off the
streets so the youngest one in the
program it's 14 years old and she's
pregnant now four months pregnant the
latest girl in the arriving in the house
was is 16 years old and she already has
a baby nine month old the pregnancy and
the baby are both consequences of the
life they were rescued from a visit
coincided with renovations to the center
a cement delivery is a moment of
excitement that makes you realize they
are only kids then there was the short
girl she has learning disabilities and
she's 16 another 16 who was very helpful
when we carried the cement
and very happy to do it she doesn't want
this to be about her but they'd be on
the streets if it wasn't for her they're
very young and they end up in a very
abusive situation and then when they
give the courage and seek help
they are then again blamed by the
society somehow they it's their fault or
they knew what they get themselves into
it's not like that at all these girls
are survivors and in my opinion they are
the heroes it is a caring place but
honestly it is rundown it's not where
you'd expect vulnerable young people to
be rehabilitated but then it is Aliana
can do the funding the money to keep
this going how much of that money is
coming from the government well from the
government none zero according to the
latest available figures from 2017 51%
of people trafficked worldwide are
children 76% of female and 69% of
victims are trafficked for sex Romania
has the highest number of victims in
Europe you see an increase in the
numbers because these girls don't cross
the border yet they are trained groomed
whatever here in the flats when they are
very young and then as soon as they turn
13 maybe 14 you can put a lot of makeup
on take them on the street and then when
they turn 18 you export them in England
England wherever you want
the following day we head south with
IANA she wants to show us the area of
the country the girls come from we
passed those who are still in the
industry look at the girls carefully and
at the end of the road do you tell me
how many of them were miners if you can
pick up the age because you they're
heavily made-up but under the makeup
they're very young yes
Craiova is known to have a particular
problem with trafficking joint
operations with other police forces
including the UK a common but
prosecutions often fail local corruption
blamed in February a case involving 26
alleged traffickers caught in a joint UK
Romanian operation collapsed amid rumors
of corrupt investigators payoffs an
intimidation of witnesses as we leave
the town we pass poverty ripe for an
industry that feeds off it vulnerable
children desperate families ruthless
traffickers
where is the society where do you you
grow up in a society where there are
some norms and you know what is not good
what is good in today's Europe there are
parents who sell their children because
the society its num-num and there is
only so much people like IANA can do
mark stone Sky News in Romania